I've always wanted to carry this
microphone it's a throwback BIGBANG
style we are in Leonard and Sheldon's
apartment Big Bang Theory
let's take you on a little tour that's
Kaley Cuoco giving et a peek behind the
scenes of season 1 in 2007 Penny's gonna
have to help out in this apartment it's
little it to a boyish if you go in my
apartment everything's pink and bubbly
would you like to join us for Thai food
and a Superman movie marathon a marathon
Wow super movies are there you're
kidding right
the actress dished on landing the role
of Penny revealing she didn't get the
part at first because producer Chuck
Lorre didn't think she was old enough
this show for me has been circulating
for so long I actually had read for it
two years ago when they had done it and
didn't get the job and Chuck was like
you're just too young I was like okay
and went away and then they write her
they're reshooting I'm like and then I
got the collar do you want to come back
into network doing we still interested
in you and I was like oh I don't know
let me see maybe that I came in I got
the job and we got picked up and it was
like this whirlwind weird Johnny's the
cutest thing in the world I have a
little set crush on him it's just the
cutest just so great just so delicious
okay her apartments on the fourth floor
but the elevator is broken so you can
just kind of beat done okay cool thanks
I guess we'll just pray it up ourselves
oh I hardly think so Jim Parsons is my
idol he's so hilarious this man is so
funny and he'll read his life I go Jim
did you study this weekend
the key to the studier I just left him
he's a genius
honestly Jim Parsons is a genius that's
all I have to say are you listening to
yourself it is well-established
Superman's flight as a feat of strength
it is an extension of his ability to
leap tall buildings an ability he
derives from exposure to Earth's Yellow
Sun I'm just gonna go wash up sometimes
we'll be sitting around and they'll be
having these kind of deep conversations
and I'm thinking they're reading the
script another kind of listening and I
think sometimes I get a look yeah they
have moments where them like whoa okay
Leonard okay Sheldon like whoa it's
funny cuz Jonny keeps bringing in this
really dorky backpack and I keep making
fun of him but he like loves it and it's
just there's moments where I think they
are their characters and Kaleigh
admitted there's a lot of penny and her
too she's just so loud and it basically
like me she's just all over the place
and they just don't get her so it's
gonna take some time to kind of you know
become friends first men right I don't
know I think that's what she's gonna
learn I think that she is looking for
someone like this and and Johnny
starters so just in the suite with her
just loves her and I think she just
doesn't get it yet so when she finally
does I don't know maybe something will
happen
[Music]
[Applause]